[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti lo dico subito io
questa mattina non dovrei essere qui a
parlarvi di questioni di genere e di
ragazze che stanno cambiando il mondo e
non dovrei essere qui perché sono un
uomo ho 48 anni una vita abbastanza
normale una compagna un figlio maschio
per di più non dovrei essere qui
soprattutto perché io sono un condensato
di stereotipi e gusti maschili chiedo
però anche un po di indulgenza
sono nato nel 1972 nel sud d'italia e
quando sono nato
ero immerso in tutta una serie di luoghi
comuni ne condivido qualcuno con voi
forse ci ritroviamo anche era abbastanza
scontato considerare che un bambino
maschio fosse portato per le scienze o
per il pensiero logico matematico una
bambina ovviamente per le scienze
umanistiche oppure una donna
intelligente colta curiosa avrebbe avuto
di fronte a sé un percorso da maestra un
docente universitario invece era
chiaramente un percorso segnato per un
uomo
ma proviamo a vedere forse peggiori di
questi stereotipi il governo a chi
avreste affidato il governo di una casa
è quello di una nazione o di un'impresa
ora fortunatamente i tempi sono cambiati
abbiamo fatto tantissima strada da
allora forse non tantissimi ma in realtà
dobbiamo ancora farne in realtà di
strada
sta di fatto che nonostante io sia nato
in questa cultura
a un certo punto della mia vita circa
undici anni fa ho iniziato a occuparmi
di questioni di genere partendo dalle
bambine e dalle ragazze
i motivi non li conosco neanch'io
probabilmente è stato l'esempio materno
forse il fatto che ho incontrato sulla
strada donne coraggiose consapevoli
indomite oppure come si dice è stato lo
spirito dei tempi che in qualche maniera
ci trascina tutti sta di fatto che 11
anni fa io come credo molti di voi ho
incontrato una parola quella parola era
femminicidio è a fianco a quella parola
un numero quel numero
nel 2009 era 119 ed è cresciuto
drammaticamente negli anni successivi
era il numero delle donne o delle
ragazze uccise da mariti fidanzati
compagni amanti per il semplice fatto di
essere donne
ed è per questo che proprio perché
questo stava accadendo in italia in quel
momento insieme a un gruppo di colleghi
e colleghe di terre des homme
l'organizzazione per cui lavoro abbiamo
iniziato a lanciare una campagna ea fare
un lavoro di ricerca di progetti di
storie di testimonianze e di dati i
numeri lo so sono sempre noiosissimi
però mi hanno detto che ha un tè dix
posso permettermi di condividerne
qualcuno con voi vi ruberà poco tempo e
chiedo la vostra pazienza e attenzione
45 milioni e il numero delle donne che
mancano all'appello
dal 1970 al 2017 a causa di aborti
selettivi o infanticidi sono morte per
un semplice motivo erano o sarebbero
state femmine non c'era nessun altra
ragione 200 milioni e il numero delle
donne che in questo momento hanno subito
una qualche forma di mutilazione
genitale quest'anno nel 2020
probabilmente al 34 milioni di bambine
subiranno la stessa sorte 12 milioni il
numero delle ragazze che nel corso dello
scorso anno sono state costrette a
sposarsi con un uomo spesso molto più
vecchio di loro 15 milioni e il numero
delle ragazze fra i 14 e 19 anni
che subiscono ogni anno una qualche
forma di violenza sessuale e poi
l'ultimo numero
e un numero tutto italiano 5939 il
numero dei minori che lo scorso anno
sono state vittime di reato in italia
solo che il 60 54 per cento di queste
vittime erano bambine o ragazze e quando
parliamo di reati che hanno attinenza
con la sfera sessuale
queste percentuali schizzano intorno all
80 o 90 per cento
ora immaginate l'amarezza da uomo di
essere consapevole di essere parte del
problema perché noi uomini lo siamo non
tiriamoci indietro siamo una parte
importante di questo problema ed
immaginate però anche quella sorta di
consapevolezza che se siamo parte del
problema
forse possiamo essere anche parte della
soluzione
ed è per quello che forse dovrei essere
qui e forse anche altri uomini
dovrebbero essere qui e dovrebbero
essere qui
lasciandosi anche ispirare da quelle
stesse parole che qualche anno fa hanno
ispirato a me i miei colleghi
prendiamoci cura delle bambine e loro
cambieranno il mondo
io so che può sembrare una frase in
fatica quelli slogan che spesso le
organizzazioni come la mia ripetono per
attirare un po di attenzione però nel
tempo che mi rimane vorrei raccontarvi
due storie di bambine ragazze che stanno
già cambiando il mondo in maniera molto
molto concreta
la prima storia è quella di mara la
yousafzai malanno yousafzai diventa
famosa 11 anni grazie a un blog
pubblicato dalla bbc
in quel blog
racconta quello che sta accadendo nel
suo paese il pakistan
l'arrivo di talebani la conquista dei
territori da parte loro ma soprattutto
parla del diritto all'istruzione e alla
partecipazione delle bambine e delle
ragazze in un paese come il suo pochi
anni dopo e il 9 ottobre del 2012
due giorni prima che venga celebrata per
la prima volta la giornata mondiale
delle bambine e delle ragazze che
proprio grazie a malalai nata l'autobus
che riporta ma l'ala da scuola insieme
ai suoi compagni viene assalito da un
commando di talebani che le sparano
alcuni colpi alla testa vogliono
lanciare un segnale chiaro che le
ragazze in età da marito quindi
significa 13 14 anni a scuola non devono
andarci
mara la fortunatamente sopravvive e nel
2014 riceve un premio nobel per la pace
e la più giovane ad aver ottenuto questo
riconoscimento e grazie a questo
riconoscimento il suo messaggio un
bambino un insegnante un libro e una
penna cambieranno il mondo diventano una
sorta di programma politico per decine
di governi che varano leggi emettono
risorse per combattere il gender gap
educativo bambine che stanno già
cambiando il mondo con il loro esempio
la seconda storia è quella di amica
amica george amica un sorriso
meraviglioso è nata nel 2000 in un
sobborgo di londra da genitori di
origine indiana con questo sorriso
dovreste stare attenti perché mi
incontra per strada e potrebbe
sorprendervi a bruciapelo con una
domanda imbarazzante
qual è l'ultima volta che è parlato del
suo ciclo mestruale
in realtà amica non parla soltanto del
suo ciclo mestruale parla
di una cosa che viene chiamata westphal
poverty o period poverty and the quella
forma di povertà associata al mancato
accesso gratuito ad assorbenti o altri
prodotti per l'igiene mestruale colpisce
milioni di ragazze in tutto il mondo
anche nelle nostre città amica crede
così tanto al suo impegno che qualche
anno fa ha lanciato un movimento free
period e soprattutto ha lanciato una
raccolta di firme una petizione che in
poco tempo ha raccolto 200 mila firme
firme che si sono trasformate in una
spinta poderosa che ha costretto il
governo della gran bretagna a stanziare
un milione e mezzo di sterline per
combattere la povertà mestruale ma non
solo il suo esempio ha fatto nascere
movimenti in tanti altri paesi tanto che
il 2018 due parlamenti per la prima
volta quello della scozia è quello della
nuova zelanda hanno varato leggi per
rendere completamente accessibili in
maniera gratuita
i prodotti per l'igiene mestruale alle
ragazze in età scolare
prendiamoci cura delle bambine lo
cambieranno il mondo lo stanno già
facendo e insieme a loro e insieme
ammalare insieme all'amica lo stanno
facendo anche re tatum berg libri lidl
landini e ma gonzalez musu al mediano a
mela castro scene di borg e l'italiana
federica gasbarro ilaria bidini fa
chiarezza
in realtà migliaia di attiviste
giovanissimi stanno cambiando
il mondo stanno scendendo in piazza con
un pennarello un cartone degli
assorbenti e stanno sfidando i nostri
tabù si stanno prendendo cura di noi si
stanno prendendo cura del diritto delle
nostre figlie a vivere in un mondo senza
violenza che però è anche il diritto di
ognuno di noi a vivere in un mondo senza
abusi e senza prevaricazioni si stanno
prendendo cura del diritto delle nostre
figlie a sposare chiunque soltanto per
amore ma attenzione anche il nostro
diritto di seguire liberamente le nostre
emozioni e le nostre inclinazioni
sessuali si stanno prendendo cura del
diritto delle nostre figlie e anche dei
nostri figli di andare a scuola senza
correre il rischio che un loro coetaneo
giri armato di un ak47 o di un pugnale
da caccia si stanno prendendo cura del
diritto all'istruzione delle nostre
figlie che però è anche il diritto che
ognuno di noi di vivere in un mondo più
pacifico e possibilmente più ricco si
stanno prendendo cura del nostro
ambiente
prendendosi cura del futuro di ognuno di
noi
ma se loro si stanno prendendo cura di
noi ci chiedono anche di prenderci cura
di loro ci chiedono di prenderci cura di
loro permettendogli di crescere
fiduciosi e consapevoli e sicuri di
poter giocare alla pari con i loro
coetanei maschi ci chiedono di prenderci
cura dei loro spazi di libertà perché
sono anche i nostri spazi di libertà e
ci chiedono di prenderci cura dei loro
diritti perché
i diritti sono una cosa così bella che
quando viene coltivata hanno una
capacità di contagiare il mondo
positivamente di diventare un faro
capace di illuminare anche quei luoghi
in cui diritti non sono ancora arrivati
ci chiedono di prenderci cura delle loro
parole e di lasciarsi ispirare dalla
loro forza
vedete io credo che il tempo delle
ragazze e dei ragazzi in generale è
sempre quello dell'oggi ma è anche
quello del futuro il nostro tempo per
prenderci cura di loro e lasciarle
cambiare il mondo
purtroppo è soltanto quello dell'oggi
io non credo che dovremmo farci sfuggire
l'occasione
prendiamoci cura delle bambine loro
cambieranno il mondo lo stanno già
facendo
grazie
[Applauso]